what your responsibility for making that
collaboration happen and your
responsibility for having it failed well
i'll take all responsibility you know i
am the owner of the team
and if it's not working it's really up
to me
and this is why you know we're making a
change
yeah i'm disappointed i'm very
disappointed and i don't know and i
don't think that that owner is around
the organization like that but i was
very disappointed when i heard this news
because i thought brian flores he did a
great job of coming in there and really
changing the locker room around you talk
about changing the culture that's
exactly what he was trying to do and now
they're talking about well there's some
disagreements between like the future of
the hit
the general manager they had
disagreements on the quarterback and the
future of the franchise and i'm like the
head coach is more important than the
general manager the general manager is
responsible for going out there getting
talent but ultimately the coach knows
exactly the type of player that he wants
so to me if anything the general manager
should have been gone not brian flores
and when you're coming in as a young
black coach it takes a lot it takes a
lot for him to step in there and make a
lot of tough decisions and do things
that make people uncomfortable but in
order to win in order to win to the on
the next level you have to make people
uncomfortable you have to make some
decisions that
might offend some people and you know
for the life of me the goal was to beat
the patriots right
he beat the patriots twice he beat
belichick twice in one year and to me
how do you fire a guy off of that you
know is his personality too strong is he
not a do boy like you want him to like i
i just didn't understand and i'm very
very disappointed because any any owner
any organization should appreciate what
brian flores was doing
for this team and i'm just i'm very very
disappointed this is definitely a step
back
i'll be stunned if he doesn't get
another job and get another job quickly
he's been more successful than the gm
and that's where this doesn't make sense
right he's been more successful than the
gm the gm's been there going all the way
back he was the director of scouting
going back to 2007. miami doll has been
a bad team for a long time been the gm
since 2016. they have done they had some
great teams since 2016 and the
disagreement from which i continue to
hear was that flores wanted to draft
herbert which would have been a better
pick than tua it too was okay i don't
want to come down on tua justin herbert
would have been a better pick brian
flores wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait in the
owner what do you think
wait wait wait wait wait you see
come on man they can't win with tour
they can't win with tour they just can't
win with tour and i i think brian flores
probably wanted desean watson
but when you look and you go out there
and you see the type of aggressive style
defense that they play they you know
rebuilding off into line and then you
have touah and every time tua gets hit
or he drops back you're thinking
interception you're thinking injury and
to me you just can't play football like
that when you're afraid of your your um
quarterback getting constantly getting
hurt you're afraid of your your
quarterback um throwing an interception
you know i just
i wasn't sold on tour either i loved him
at alabama you know he did his thing but
in the pros he's just not that guy he's
getting better he's he's an average
quarterback he's nothing special about
tour just it's nothing special about
them on a professional level jack that's
all i'm saying
i i i agree with you i agree with you
but you could see greer and you could
see ross the owner getting together and
making the pick of two right that they
collectively had trumped flores who was
a new guy to the program and go no no
we're going to take two so then they're
just going to go out together and go oh
well if we missed this we have to
continue to ride down this path and get
on this and flores is going no i said i
was against really beginning i'm still
against this we're winning off good
defense you know we just had a 10 win
season now we had a nine win season it's
because of what we're doing within the
foundation of this program and they're
still stuck up so you got this tug and
pull right you got two guys at the top
who want one quarterback you got the
coach who's winning the games who wants
to go a different direction and you've
it's not specific to miami dolphins this
happens in other places right where you
have coach and gm or front offices who
want to do different things and it
always seems to come back to the
quarterback position my guess is that
another team it may be chicago it may be
shoot any of these openings new york
another team is going to very quickly go
brian flores a guy who now is
experienced the guy who was just
trending upward maybe faster than any
young coach in football any new coach in
football he's a perfect hire for any
other program i think it's insane i
think it's absolutely insane that after
three seasons especially the way they're
trending that you would move on from
brian flores to me it's it's one of them
it's one of the single biggest front
office mistakes that i've seen maybe in
the last five or ten years
absolutely and you see emmanuel acho and
you see a lot of these people sending
these texts these um tweets man because
i felt the same way like i thought he
was doing an excellent job i thought he
had full command of the locker room i
thought he was really changing the
culture and bringing some toughness he
beat bill belichick twice in a year
who's done that like not many have done
that you know what i'm saying and i'm
just i'm just so disappointed listen
i've i played against the dolphins i've
been following the dolphins when was the
last time the dolphins were in the super
bowl
proof was it one
last time i know they went undefeated
was that 72 the 17 1972 that was the
year i was born that's right
[Laughter]
so man to me but you know what maybe
this is the best thing for brian flores
he got a chance to go down there and
really get some some coaching experience
and wherever he goes to the next place
they're going to get a damn good coach
but also they're going to get a guy
that's highly experienced so i'm rooting
i know we're both rooting for brian
flores he'll bounce back on his feet no
question about it and maybe it's in
denver
yeah yeah that's right that's a good one
too but you know what you know it's bad
management too is when you lose seven
games early in the year and then you win
eight out of your last nine it's not
like it was the opposite they got hot
towards the end of the year and then
you're just like oh no let's move on
it's like that's when you know there's
something there's something fishy with
that one let's get to the next one which
is the giants this is a recent it's sort
of a breaking newser they move on from
joe judge how surprised are you to hear
that
i'm not i was i was more surprised to
hear that joe judge got a head coaching
job i'm like i was in the patriots
organization i never knew joe judge like
who the hell is joe judge you know and
all of a sudden he gets this head
coaching job and he's yelling he's
talking about a clown show in the
washington football team and you could
just see his inexperience and for joe
judge
maybe it was a money grab to get as much
money as he possibly could and then now
he can go back and be an assistant and
he doesn't have to be the front guy but
i was really stunned that the giants
hired this guy and these organization
organizations they keep hiring these
guys keep firing them no stability it's
it's crazy to me man and these are
billion dollar companies and they don't
know what the heck they're doing it's
just like they're flushing money down
the drain and it's like do you evaluate
football like do you have really good
peep football people around you to let
you know when a decision is good or bad
are you just doing this
off of analytics i just don't understand
these organizations anymore bro
you sum that one up all right let's get
to another firing that we have the bears
matt nagy this is one that you could
probably go back to about
week five or six maybe week eight at the
latest and you knew this one was coming
the bears let him coach out the season
because it seems to be what they do it's
part of their process to let them no
matter how bad it gets they're gonna let
you burn down with the house that you
built
maggie gone
where the heck do they go from here
man let me let me tell you this is no
surprise to me and this is something
i've been calling for for a while you
know matt nagy wasn't good he just
wasn't good i mean for him to come in
and give andy dalton the job that's the
thing that really pissed me off because
you know you can't give a guy a job we
we're all professionals we're in the
locker room we're fighting and clawing
for our families for our team and you
give a guy a job like who the heck is
andy dalton for you to give him anything
what has he done what has he won you
know what i'm saying is like andy dalton
you're giving him a job and when matt
maggie did that
being a guy from the chicagoland area i
was very disappointed and i knew the
bears would not have a great season then
you think about the defense all the
wasted time all the talent all those
guys have gotten older keem hicks has
gotten older khalil mack eddie um
jackson he's you know they need to move
on from him paying him 14 15 million
bucks a year and he's he stinks up the
place so if it's me once again i'm
looking at a jim caldwell i'm looking at
an eric being in me i'm looking at a
buyer left with somebody that can come
in and work directly with justin fields
and really just take to be able to take
him to the next level
i'm right there with you offensive coach
that's what nagy was brought in there to
do and they never played good offense
and they scored 18 points per game on
offense this year he's had two
quarterbacks an opportunity to do it
trubisky justin fields i mean if anybody
should be impatient it was naggy it's
that he's playing the patient game and
bye bye vikings that's that's a place
who was pretty patient with their coach
coach zemer eight years he had
you know some great defenses if you go
back three or four years top of the
league that has fallen off since sort of
post hovering really since the covet
season they've been at the bottom of the
nfl now zimmer that final game without
kirk cousins who was out with covet as
they went in there to play the packers
he is on his way out from the vikings
look man and he said it i mean they
tried everything they could in the eight
years that he was there but to me the
vikings just need they need some fresh
young energy they just need something
fresh they need to get rid of kubiak as
the um the sun kubiak what's his name
clint kubiak the offensive coordinator i
think he's horrible they need to get rid
of him justin jefferson alluded to it
many of times that he's not happy with
the offense and he's your star player
adam thielen is starting to get a little
older he's starting to get hurt dalvin
cook is still very very efficient
but at the end of the day man you got to
move on and you got to get ahead a new
head coach in there that's going to
bring some energy bring some excitement
get that defense back flying around
playing well they're getting older so
you know you look at you look at this
job you try to figure out well they
still guaranteed kirk cousins 35 million
dollars this year so do you as an
organization do you pay
15 20 million of that and try to trade
him or do you keep him and pay him a
full 35 million dollars like what
organization guarantees kirk cousins 35
million bucks it's just ridiculous i'm
happy for kurt but at the end of the day
if you're trying to win a championship
it's not going to be like that and kurt
has played well for him
right he has he has and their defenses
have just gone he sort of took him up
and they've come right back down ever
since i think zimmer will link on as a
defensive coordinator somewhere and i
think we'll see him yeah
he's creative i mean shoot he does
things that screw with aaron rodgers
mind so he's a creative mind and i think
he'll be a good fit 65 years old still
got some good career ahead of him new
energy new coach will be heading into
the program
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports